if I was 22 I would get in front of a
camera and stream all day it is very
clear to me that live is the opportunity
right now attention is the number one
asset for all three of you I couldn't
push you more enough to do Tik Tok live
all day long brushing your teeth driving
make pretend you're late on the train to
a meeting I don't have to give a keynote
I'm about to stop this and go on mute
people going to watch in the background
me going on with my day and that's
interesting because it's an Insight
because I can tell you this 16-year-old
me would have looked up to Gary ve and
would have thought it was cool
to see how he does his day I'm like okay
I'm huge on watching people being
observant and watching how people move
so when I watch people work I take what
I can and that's why like I'm so blessed
to be living in this area is like
there's so much free game out
there you just got to pay attention and
you just got to look for it